welcome everyone this evening to our
spring lecture or our late winter
lecture however we shall think about it
these days and welcome on behalf of the
st. basil society I am its director
Cyril Jenkins and I welcome you all here
to st. Philip's Parish and we thank st.
Philip's Parish for hosting us this year
very kindly they've agreed to do so and
thank you to father James for leading us
in Vespers just a bit ago father Noah
sends his regards he could not be here
because he's at a conference I said okay
then if that's the way it is father and
so I welcome you all here tonight and
tonight were privileged to have mr.
Jonathan pezzo Jonathan is from Montreal
I first heard of him some years ago upon
the death of a friend namely father
Matthew Baker of blessed memory
Jonathan was asked to do his headstone
his gravestone which you can actually
see pictures of online and it is a
beautiful piece and the thing about
Jonathan is it's it's a headstone that
is a carving and Jonathan is really the
only person in North America who does
carvings that is icons in stone but
that's not all he does so even though I
had first heard about him then I had
heard about him also because of the the
Orthodox arts Journal which a mutual
friend had basically told me about
and so the Orthodox Archdeacon find
online that can be delivered to your
inbox and it's a wonderful resource and
Jonathan writes there and also Jonathan
has now taken up video blogging and so
he has a YouTube channel called the
symbolic world and some of this stuff is
great some of this stuff you might think
what what what did he just say
but I I came across this video blog
because a few months ago course I'm in
the Academy which means that I guess
this is being taped out to be careful
what that means but but I'm always
interested in people who are always kind
of sticking it to academics and so there
was this one particular bete noire this
dark beast out there named Jordan
Peterson and wait he's on the video with
Jonathan Bush Oh what are they they were
talking about Pepe the Frog am i oh my
word
but I've come to find out that of course
that's not really what they were talking
about right what we're really looking at
is we're looking at in many ways a
transformation before our eyes of
culture and in a revolutionary way and
so tonight Jonathan's going to come and
talk to us about this and talk to us
about this with respect to how do we as
Orthodox think about these things think
about the world around us right that the
world is far more than what we see with
our mere eyes that is it is a world full
of symbols and they're just waiting
there for us to interpret them
Jeremiah Hopkins said that the world is
filled with the splendor of God and that
Christ plays in 10,000 places and so
hopefully tonight we can understand that
a little better
so Jonathan shall speak hopefully we
shall have time for food we will have
time for food because we have a lot of
food so please stay but also time for
question and answers and then some brief
remarks at the end but Jonathan the
floor is yours
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world I
basically decided I was good to take on
the last pretty much five hundred years
of history and just Duke it out with it
so I was still changing my nodes in the
plane so I first of all I want to thank
and I thank all you for having me here
and I want to thank dr. Jenkins for
inviting me I was I'm always surprised
when I get invited by academic types
because I'm not I'm not myself an
academic I I I read and I and I and I
study on my own but I took my route out
of the university after I finished my
bachelor's degree in painting quite a
while ago but I am I I'm very curious
about as an artist and as someone who
took on iconography and took on icon
carving specifically I always curious to
see how the imagery in the icons how it
connects to the Bible how it connects to
liturgy how it connects to the hymns how
it connects to the whole tradition of
the church but then most of all I'm
always looking to see how does it
connect to our experience today how does
it connect to the world in which we live
in and so the title that that dr.
Jenkins gave me for the talk is I think
it's Christ as the center and the
principle of the enchanted world and so
that's actually it's it's it's it can
sound as something that's quite obscure
and so in order to talk about what it
means what are we talking about when we
talk about the enchanted world we have
to understand even where that word
kind of originated from the notion of
the enchanted world originated from its
opposite originated from thinkers like
Friedrich Schiller and Max Weber who
talked about the disenchantment of the
world as Max Weber especially was
looking at how the modern world was
laying itself out he was noticing how
things were happening in the modern
world he was noticing that the world was
being disenchanted that the magic in the
world was going away that is as the as
the scientific thinking became more and
more prominent as we had more and more
detailed mechanical physical
explanations for how things happen
the ancient spiritual reasons which were
given the ancient spiritual stories
which undergirded the world started to
lose their power and to dissipate so the
forest was no longer this place of
darkness and mystery but the forest
became a reservoir of wood from which we
could take stuff and then make things
with right the Sun was no longer what
this this this this bright light that
traversed the sky and gave us light and
life like a like an eye which acrosses
across the sky it was just a ball of gas
with nuclear explosions whirling around
the void and it was just one amongst
trillions and trillions and trillions of
similar stars is absolutely nothing
special about that Sun see in
traditional societies people are
connected to transcendent reality those
transcendent realities are undergirded
by stories by rituals by identities and
those those those connections to to
trance
realities are what gives them their
identity are what make them give them
their identity as individuals but also
their identity as groups how the
individuals come together and then also
identity through time so we think that's
obvious like we think it's we it is not
that obvious that let's say here in in
the United States that whatever is here
is somehow the same thing that was there
when the founding fathers started at
hundreds of years ago there has to be a
story which undergirds all of that
together to make us continue to inhabit
a space where those are the same right
and traditional societies that's how
they function that's how they they they
are connected together and so now today
we hear the type of argument which is
the argument of disenchantment the one
that Max Weber was talking about this
argument which tries to destroy to
attack the connection to the
transcendent to attack the value of
stories the value of identities we see
it all the time and we want to reduce
the world to its material substrate to
material causation you know and
scientific relationships between things
and so for example an easy example is
that in in let's say in the traditional
Christian world what we would have
talked about someone who was possessed
by a demon but now today we mark that
idea because we can go into the brain
and we can look at the different
chemicals in the brain and we can say no
this person just has a chemical
imbalance of this type in the brain and
so it is absolutely superstitious to say
that that person is possessed by a demon
and the ultimate version of this the
ultimate version of this would be to
take the blood and body of Christ as it
is
sit crated and bring it in to a lab to
have it analyzed and you wouldn't be
surprised to know that people have done
that and you wouldn't be surprised to
find out that the conclusion the
scientists came to is that it's bread
and wine it's not body and blood and so
the Atheist type will see this
disenchantment as a getting rid of
superstition right because it is
superstitious to believe in God or
angels or to believe that going to
church and worshipping some God is
somehow magically going to save you
magically going to make you a better
person
what is that magically heal you how is
that it's just a superstitious way to
see the thing and the Bible is no
different right if you reduce everything
to its material substrate then the Bible
is no different than any other book and
you can look at it you can read it you
can analyze you can take it apart in the
same way that you can take apart any
other ancient or modern book and the
church building is no different right
the stuff that's in the altar the air
the molecules the atoms they're the same
stuff that are in the nave and they are
the same stuff that are in the bathroom
and so to say that somehow the altar is
special that it's sacred is a
superstition and as we move down that
line what happens and what has happened
is that inevitably we come to question
the value question the authority of all
narratives of all authority because in a
way there is no mechanical explanation
for why one person has Authority or why
one story has value it is all
superstition it all seems arbitrary
so that is the disenchanted world and
the disenchanted world it leads to two
extremes and those are the extremes that
we have seen in the modern world it
leads to a form of brutal violence form
of raw power this idea of the
realpolitik which was developed in the
modern world this idea that states are
only brute forces which are there to
impose orders because there is no
natural there is no spiritual reason to
believe in an authority the only thing
left is brute power in order to in a way
prevent the fragmentation for prevent
things from falling apart we need these
these these totalitarian powers and we
saw that in the totalitarian regimes of
the 20th century and luckily for us we
here in North America we didn't have to
go through the totalitarian side of that
of that opposition but we had the other
side which is the other thing that the
disenchantment causes is nihilism
and that nihilism ends up being this
lack of centers these lack of value and
things start to fragment to lose their
meaning to lose their natural importance
you could say and we end up in a world
that is without center and meaningless
so I'm supposed to talk about the
Incarnation how the Incarnation is the
center and the principle of the
enchanted world now this will stop me
from saying heretical things so don't
worry from that one okay so I'm supposed
to talk about how the Incarnation is the
center and the principle of this
enchanted world maybe this enchanted
world that we have lost but in a way to
say that to put those three together the
Incarnation center and principle is
maybe a tautological we might actually
be seen saying the same thing when we
say those three things the notion of a
center is itself incarnation --all it is
a promise of the Incarnation and it
corresponds with its principle and
that's why such a brilliant Saint such
as st. Maximus the Confessor could take
the notion of origin of purpose of
meaning and bring them all together in
this vision of the logos in this vision
this expansion of this vision of the
logos which we find in the Gospel of st.
John and all of this is brought into the
notion of the logos and its incarnation
into the world and we have this notion
that the Logie that that that the logo
that the Logie in the world that these
manifestations of logos in the world are
all gathered together brought together
into Christ Christ is the summit and the
center of all things and then being the
summit and the center of all things as
it comes back down into the world
Christ is the logos and the origin of
the world a pattern which is hidden in
the entire creation you see a center is
by definition something around which
things turn okay something it both the
center both defines space but it also
binds space together if you think of it
even in terms of geometry okay it
creates an identity so in terms of
geometry the the point the center is
actually without measurement it doesn't
have it is it is virtual it is it is it
is invisible but it is the thing which
holds a space together it is the thing
which which binds a circle together and
that's why churches temples are rituals
they are there they're concentric we
have the holy place towards which we all
face towards which we all turn in that
holy place the altar acts as a center it
and it acts as the point which define
the community of the Christians it acts
as the point which unites the community
of Christians you can go even farther
it's not just the altar but it is the
cup on the altar and the vendôme and the
wine in the bread in the cup you know it
is this concentric movement towards this
now invisible mystery which is hidden in
communion and which is real and present
but which is a mystery but just in
general we have these invisible
identities which define us and bind us
together it's not only communion it's
not only church but it's that's the
shape of the world we have these
identities which defined us it could be
our family it can be our our nation and
there are there are many of these
identities but these identities
invisible identities act in a similar
manner they bind us together and then we
have these markers of these these these
invisible identities we have flags we
have heroes we have leaders we have
special cities capitals buildings things
which remind us of this invisible
mystery which holds us together so the
center of something right it has there's
something special about it there's
something which differentiates it from
everything else which pulls it above
everything else which makes it
qualitatively different from whatever it
holds together and in the the thrust of
disenchantment right in this movement
that happened in modernity this moving
of this desire to destroy all
superstition we see this levelling of
quality this notion that everybody is
the same everybody is equal because in
the material way that is obviously true
right I need a priest in terms of his
body as a in terms of its physical
existence is no different or no better
than anybody else in the parish and we
see that you know in kind of extreme
that say antibiotics are kind of
evangelical thinking where it's like
we're all the same but the notion of the
priest or the notion of the center in
general is that something will be will
be pulled up will be made special will
be made to act as a Center and that is
it's an invisible quality it's not you
can't you can't you can't measure it
right you can't you can't measure a
priest's priesthood
and so in this disenchantment any Center
will start to appear as a one more
superstition and it's a gradual breaking
apart and it's not necessarily done
consciously it just happens it's a
natural consequence of the modern world
we see this disenchantment everywhere
right of course we like I've been trying
to explain to you this notion of center
can be taken analogically as any
identity but a good way to see the
effect of disenchantment is to look at
it in space I mean I'm an artist I tend
to think in terms of space and so you
can look at how society actually lays
itself out on the ground how it how it
builds itself out and you can see the
disenchantment happening so if you
imagine for example a medieval town
right how is the medieval town organized
you would have in the center of the town
you would have a church and the church
would be the highest building in the
town so everybody from anywhere in the
city in the town could look up and they
could see the church as this central
point and then in the middle of the town
you would also have you know an
administrative building the mayor's
house or the mayor's building or
whatever and you would have a central
place where people would come and could
gather together and participate in
things which would unite them as a town
parades you know any type of festivities
they would come and they would meet in
the center of a town and in the modern
world these types of structs and on the
edge then you would have a wall which
would be the limit of what the town the
identity of the town this is the end of
the town which is identified by all
these things together and the roads in
the town would be concentric if you look
at a medieval town from above it looks
like
fighter well you have these roads which
leave from the wall and move towards the
center of town then you have these other
roads that connect those concentric
roads together it looks like a spiderweb
so it is built by meaning it is built by
identity it's actual layout is based on
what gathers those people together now
in the modern world this has slowly
eroded it took a while took a while but
it slowly eroded in the last few hundred
years we've seen it eroded until we've
come to the suburban sprawl I mean what
is exactly a suburban sprawl these
clumps of houses this grid of houses
just no center nothing to bind it
together nothing to hold it together no
church no set no Town Square nothing
right the last vestige of a town centre
is the shopping mall that's the last
vestige you know and it can maybe show
you this degrading of value what it is
that we turn around the last thing left
is the shopping mall and even that it's
going to go away it's going to disappear
disenchantment will take its course we
can imagine a future very close by where
people study online work from home shop
online and there is nothing to bring
them together there is no moment where
they will come together they are
basically become independent point
points spread out on a surface drip of
paint thrown out on a canvas they're
basically a big Jackson Pollock painting
do you know a Jackson Pollock painting I
mean who would have thought that Jackson
Pollock was actually representing
suburban America I don't think he would
have thought that
this is a form of alienation this is an
image of alienation of being ripped away
from whatever it is that can bring us
together whatever it is that can give us
common reason common identity common
purpose that is alienation you know in
an alienation has been a common theme in
modernity even the people who were for
modernism who were pushing modernity
could notice it happening you know you
see commentators in the existentialists
than people like that who talk
constantly about modern man's alienation
they know that it's happening and yeah
the suburban sprawl is the last phase of
alienation there is a more profound
there is a more original alienation
which is at the core of all of this and
we can see it in terms of space as well
we can we can see it in terms of space
and this is where I am going to take on
the last 500 years of intellectual
history just like a town was built
concentric Li so to the entire cosmos
was built concentric Li
so to earth man looked up at the heavens
and saw the spheres moving in this in
the heavens and interpreted them that
way saw them as moving around this
Center of meaning which is man created
in the image of God that is how the
world was built and so the the the
Copernican revolution is a is a
testimony to the very very deep change
that happened at that time we we often
miss what that change was about we're
often presented
with the Copernican revolution as this
notion that people used to mistakenly
believe that the Sun you know revolved
around the earth and now we know
technically that that is not the case
that in fact the Earth revolves around
the Sun but that is not really what the
Copernican revolution is about it was
really about a move away from this
enchanted centered experience it was a
move away from seeing meaning as the
organizing principle of the universe of
seeing this notion of center not only in
terms of mechanical movement but in
terms of centers of meaning centers of
identity as being the way that we look
at the world and the way we calculate
the world and I know this one is it
might be difficult to graph I was
actually expecting maybe a few people to
get up and get out after I said that but
luckily that hasn't happened yet you see
in order to to even perceive right that
the possibility of the earth turning
around the Sun the change had to have
already happened there had had to that
there it have to be had been a very
profound change in the way we see the
world for that to be even possible to be
posited because in order to be able to
calculate that right Copernicus and
Galileo had to alienate themselves they
had to alienate themselves they had to
project their mind to some imaginary
point out there in space and then look
imagine in their imagination at how
these fears were moving it was a
profound gesture of alienation and it's
important to
to talk about the Copernican revolution
why is it so important it's so important
because people keep talking about it
today people are always talking about it
it is one of the founding myths of the
modern world is the Copernican
revolution we we hear materialist
scientific types bring it up all the
time as an example of a moment where
religion was obscure and science was
bright we see it all the time that
that's how its presented to us the truth
is that there is there is absolutely
nothing obvious there's absolutely
nothing obvious that that that changed
would happen and and that might seem
strange to say but I can I can show it
to you quite easily because for some
reason we've stopped there for some
reason we stopped at a point where we
say the earth is revolving around the
Sun but that's not the end of it is it
right that's not the end of that
movement
we've moved quite further than that in
fact with Einstein and general
relativity we we have been told that all
motion is based on points of reference
so it's not it's not true that just that
the earth is turning around the Sun
right so the earth is turning around the
sun and then the sun is turning around
in the galaxy and then the galaxy is
moving away from other galaxies and then
the stars are all moving away from all
the other stars so let's try to figure
that movement out in our minds now ready
in order so we don't we don't go there
we don't go there because once we get
there once we get to the point that if
we're going to calculate things
in terms of mechanical causation and
mechanical movement we should have to
take up all these movements at the same
time and also realize that the earth is
turning around the Sun relative to the
Sun and the Sun is moving away from the
other stars relative to each other right
they're not actually moving in
themselves they're only moving in
relationship to other things that's
Einstein's theory that's general
relativity right and once we get there
why not what point can we give in the
universe to calculate all these
movements what point could we possibly
give would it maybe make sense to give
as a point of reference for all those
movements the one where we are making
those calculations wouldn't it make
sense to say that we're calculating all
those movements from the earth there's
actually a priest
paavo Florence key who wrote an essay
where he took these notions of general
relativity to their extreme and he said
okay let's say general relativity
seriously and let's take it so seriously
that we realize that the best position
that we can take to make all those
calculations would be from here because
this is where we are I mean makes sense
we're the ones making the calculations
right let's make those calculations and
he did all the calculations and those
calculations end up being the same as
Ptolemy's made you know 2,000 years ago
all right so I'm playing a little bit of
a game with you here what's really
important
what's really important is to understand
that we are the ones making those
calculations we are the ones not only
making the calculations but attributing
value to those calculations we are the
ones saying that those movements those
values those codes those movements have
meaning and that is really the most
important thing what do the movements of
the spheres what do the movements of the
planetary bodies mean and now that's
where the materialist type will say no
no no no no no those movements don't
mean anything right
they're just movements they don't have
meaning but if someone tells you that if
someone tells you that they don't mean
anything you can right away see that the
only way they can say that is to be
completely alienated because obviously
the movement of the heavenly spheres
have meaning the day and the night or
the structure by which we live our lives
the seasons the waxing and waning of the
moon all of these movements of the
celestial spheres they are the patterns
they are the processions in which we
exist they are the movements in which we
live our lives those are the ones that
have meaning and so once we start to
view the world through these centers of
meanings all of a sudden everything
changes
now I'm not I'm not saying that Galileo
or Copernicus that their calculations
are technically wrong I'm not not saying
that I'm not saying that they were wrong
in the calculations they were making
what I'm saying is that the real
question is deeper than that it's B it's
about it's above those calculations the
real question is what is the center of
reality what is more real right is it
mechanical causation or is it the world
of meaning is it the world in which
things are imbued with the meaning that
they have in our lives which one of
those is more real because one of them
the one where we say that the mechanical
causation has more reality brings about
that alienation the alienation that I've
been talking about since the beginning
the very alienation that brought
Copernicus and Galileo to project their
mind outside of the world and look at
the world from from from from somewhere
else right we see we see that alienation
all the time now there you hear someone
you you see especially when people are
trying to study human beings
you see these scientific studies of
culture you make you you you read
anthropologists who think that they can
stand outside of culture and that they
can interpret culture you meet some
people who are studying consciousness
and they somehow think that they can
stand outside of consciousness and study
consciousness or that they can stand
outside of language and study language
we can't do that we are living in the
world right we are we are embodied and
we we we exist in the world we we when
we do that we alienate ourselves one of
the one of the best places one of the
the
the places where you see this alienation
take on even a moral aspect and if you
pay attention to what they call the New
Atheists right Richard Dawkins and all
that clan if you pay attention to what
they're saying you will see this
alienation play itself out quite
dramatically in a moral sense you see
someone like Richard Dawkins he uses
this disenchantment argument to attack
Christianity by reducing everything to
the material efficient caught or
efficient causes he'll he'll ask he'll
ask questions like how can a body
resurrect if it is totally decomposed I
mean it's not it's that's what that's a
perfectly legitimate scientific question
to ask how can a body resurrect if it is
completely decomposed I mean the the DNA
is gone the cells are gone the plasma is
gone all it's gone what exactly is it
that's going to resurrect and he also
says that it is absurd that the bread
and wine become the blood and body of
Christ because it is still bread and
wine take it to the lab and you will see
that it is still bread and right and
since we are all material reductionists
his argument is that Christians don't
believe in the resurrection that
Christians themselves don't believe that
the communion is the body and blood of
Christ but then if you look at Dawkins a
little bit longer you'll see that he has
a very very strong sense of moral values
he has a very strong hierarchy of values
that he's a he's actually quite a
moralist quite the 'mentally so actually
but he is completely blind to the source
of his morality
right he posits materiality and material
causality as the organizing principle of
the world and so he can't see that he is
in fact motivated by invisible centers
invisible causes he can't he can't see
it right it is it is it's an alienation
right akin to the ones that I described
in terms of of the of the Copernican
Revolution but what happens is it's very
dangerous because they're the source of
morality ends up disappearing it doesn't
really disappear but it's it's it's it's
it's as if it doesn't actually exist
it's taken for granted all right he can
inhabit a certain hierarchy of values
that has centers of meanings and engages
notions even that resemble the sacred
and he gets offended right you can see
Richard Dawkins get offended like a
Puritan you know like how can you ever
say that you know blah blah it's like
where does that offense come from where
are your hidden centers of morality but
he doesn't think he has them and it's
very scary because then at the same time
he goes out and attacks it and attacks
this notion of the enchanted world this
notion of these these transcendent
meanings which are embedded in reality
he just hacks at it constantly and so
it's really the summit of alienation but
now I say that someone like Dawkins is
alienated but we need to take at least a
little bit of time and turn the mirror
towards us right towards us as
Christians I mean do we have an end
sir to someone like Richard Dawkins and
his ilk do we have an answer to give him
do we have an answer to what we are
referring to when we say the body and
blood of Christ what we are referring to
when we speak of the resurrection
because in a way maybe in a way maybe
Dawkins is right to the extent that we
ascribe to some kind of material
reductionism and if we do and when we do
shouldn't we agree with him shouldn't we
say that it's bread and wine do we have
an answer to give him so wanted to paint
a very dismal picture for you but there
is hope there is hope there's good news
because as I've already hinted so far
the world cannot cannot become
completely disenchanted cannot become
void of meaning it is impossible for the
world to become void of meaning the
world would have to cease to exist and
in the very experience of being this
enchantment these sparks these centers
they break through and we experience
them even though sometimes we're blind
to it we experience there is a path back
to the Magic Garden there is a path back
to communion so I tried to find some
very practical examples these moments
where the sparks shine for
there's plenty of but I want you to
imagine a a cup your grandmother gave
you this cup and she gave you this cup
because it was a special cup because
when you were young and you went to your
grandmother's house the this would be
the cup that you would use and so before
she passed away your grandmother she
gave you this cup so you put the cup in
your cupboard right and it becomes your
favorite cup so when you open the
cupboard that cup it shines right it's
brighter it's golden I mean it doesn't
doesn't physically glow there isn't a
lamp inside the cup but it's the best
way to describe that experience of that
cup when you open the cupboard it is the
first cup you will see and even without
thinking about it it's the first cup
that you'll reach for right and the end
of the the shine the glow of that cup
it's not just in the cup it's not it's
not physically in the cup but it is in
the story in the memory in the history
of that cup in you in communion with
that cup it is as you enter into
communion with that cup that cup will
shine now if any other stranger opens
the cupboard they look at the cup they
don't see that right they don't see that
but it is it is real it is real the the
other example that I have that I think
is to me the most immediate is is
recognizing someone there is something
there is the difference in your
experience between someone you don't
know and someone you know you're
standing in a bus and there is a crowd
of people in the box
and all those faces they are somehow dim
I mean they're not their faces they're
people but they're they they they there
is a way that we perceive strangers
which is different from the way that we
perceive the people we know now if
someone you know walks into the bus all
of a sudden that person will shine
there's no other way to say it that
person will pop out and you will see
that person your eyes will go to that
person and and and all through as
they're walking through these dim phases
it is that face which will glow in the
bus that is a real experience I have
explained you know you can experience it
sometimes you can experience it directly
you're standing in front of someone
somebody and the person is talking to
you and you don't know the person and
they're talking to you in to tell you no
are you talking to them and you're nice
and you're kind and you're being polite
and then all of a sudden the person says
something that makes you realize that no
wait I know this person if you've ever
experienced it the face their face will
change before your very eyes your the
way that you see them will transform and
all of a sudden from that stranger you
see this face of this person you know
this person with whom you are in
communion now I've used the personal
examples because they're the ones that
are the easiest to understand because
they're the ones that make it into our
own little experience you know even the
most secular atheist of us will
experience these small moments where the
world becomes magical but then this
hierarchy is real it is it is how the
world works you see there are too many
things in the world there are too many
do
there are too many facts there are too
many aspects to things and so it is
inevitable it is inescapable that
certain things certain stories certain
images will be more enchanted there's no
way around it that they will become more
meaningful than the others or else you
couldn't see anything
there is an there is an indefinite
amount of details in this one leaf right
here of this plant I could spend an hour
describing every curve every line every
every aspect of this one leaf the world
is so full of details it fragments into
chaos it moves out and becomes the sand
so it is inevitable that we have to
engage the world in this magical way
there's there's no way around it that's
how reality works now in a similar way
that my favorite cup shines and although
at another level the level which is more
encompassing which is grander which is
higher but still it's the same pattern
the cup which is used in church the cup
which is on the altar is sacred it is
really sacred it is sacred it is sacred
because it has been put aside because it
stands apart because it has been focused
it has been set aside for communion for
the communion of the faithful and it is
in with that cup that we all come
together and we stand and we approach
that cuff that all of that is real that
cup is sacred and so a darkens new
atheist type will probably resort retort
something like this
oh it's all good and nice no this is all
nice because you're talking about
subjective things you're talking about
human human things but that is not the
case for objective science right that's
not how science works that's how we
engage with things but that's not how
science works but once again that shows
that the profound alienation and once
again one forgets their own embodiment
their own embodied experience this
process this process of the center is as
true for science as it is for our
engagement with the cup that her
grandmother gave us in the cupboard I
told you there are too many facts there
are too many facts in the world there
are too many aspects of the world the
world is too big the world moves towards
this infinite this indefinite chaos so
there must necessarily be a way for
special facts to stand out now when you
do a scientific experiment you have a
theory and that theory what does it do
it makes certain facts shine it makes
certain facts glow because it becomes
the center around which facts are
organized if I am studying fungus the
facts that I will see are the facts that
are related to fungus I will not spend
my time describing the facts that talk
about cosmological principles right I
will focus on the facts which prove or
disprove my theory the facts will appear
as sorry to use the word but they will
be something like sacred in the context
of that scientific experiment in the
context of that scientific theory and I
will even organize the facts in a
hierarchy of facts and there are certain
facts which scientists will call they
call them outliers because they don't
totally fit with what the other facts
related to this theory are saying and
they will leave those facts beside those
facts will be more dim they won't shine
as brightly as the ones which are right
there right in the right place to either
prove or disprove my theory okay now I
keep talking about this notion of the
center right of this mysterious
qualitative difference you know in
something which makes it stand out in a
way you know or least makes it stand
apart I had acts as it as a to call it
an anchor in the world and this vision I
would say we could call that an
incarnation 'el vision of the world I
don't think there's anything weird about
saying that you see the world is a place
where these sparks where these meanings
where these centers these essences
organize all of these far two random
facts gathers them gathers this
multiplicity from this multiplicity
gathers them together into these
possible unities into these unified
beings all being
have Hertz right so a cup has parts why
do we think that those thing come
together and make one thing a cup has a
handle it has this why do we how what is
it that makes it bring bring it together
and say that it is one thing the United
States is a hundreds of millions of
people on a vast vast land why do we
think that this is one thing what makes
us say that this vast sprawl of people
on a vast vast land is one thing right
that's what essences do they gather
things together and the pattern for this
is set it is set there already in the
book of Genesis we find God who gathers
the dust gathers it into a body and then
blows the spirit into that body and that
is how we have man we have the notion
that Christ gathers the lost sheep
gathers the Sheep brings them together
into one body and blows his spirit right
creating one church and so to the
Mystics will tell us to gather yourself
into your heart because you're also have
all these parts you have all these
thoughts you have all these desires you
have all these passions which could pull
you in all these directions away from
the center away from the thing that
makes you in the image of God that makes
you in the image of Christ and the
mystic tells us to pull all that
together to enter
into the heart so we can encounter and
become like Christ but and even just our
experience of consciousness just our
experience of being a locust where all
of these sensations all of these things
that we see all of these people are
gathered into one person that holds that
together and makes out of all this
multiplicity one thing all of that is
following the same pattern and then by
analogy we quickly realize that that is
also the structure of all the things I
talked about before it's the same
structure as a functioning town it's the
same structure as a family as a country
it's the same thing as a church and it's
also the same as the patterns of time
the days the the months the years this
cycle this procession around this Center
of time that we participate in all of
these have the same pattern the same
pattern that was set right there in
Genesis that is room that is brought
back through Christ and through our
experience of Christianity and of course
the most complete vision of this is
Christ himself it is the Incarnation
itself of course it is the anchor of
everything it is the pattern of
everything and that's why in the
descriptions of Christ we find all these
analogies that Christ is a center that
he is a an authority Christ is portrayed
as the origin of value and meaning in
his story in the story of his life or in
the way that the Bible and the fathers
have described him we say that Christ is
priest he is king he is judge
he is Shepard he gathers the Sheep right
in this example we see Christ as the
leader as yet the authority and Christ
also tells us these amazing stories he
tells us the story of the Pearl which is
hidden in the field and gives the field
its value we have the story of st. Peter
who Christ says to go out to the water
as he goes out to the water he reaches
in and he finds this gold piece in the
mouth of the fish it is this hidden
Center right this hidden value and
that's why one of the reason why Christ
himself
he appears in his story as hidden so
many times he appears as hidden
appearing in the most humble
circumstance in the manger in the cave
he hides himself among fishermen and tax
collectors and that is really important
because this incarnation of principle
follows the motto that I've been talking
about since the beginning the reason for
things the center of things the identity
of a community the reason for my
favorite cup in the cupboard it it is
hidden it is real but it remains hidden
those reasons are contained in the
communion that we have in the way that
things come together that is how they
reveal themselves so we use the word
Christ as if it is a name but of course
the word Christ is not a name like the
word Christ is a title
it is a title which means The Anointed
One and in that image of the anointing
in that image of the Anointed One we can
find everything that I've been talking
about from the beginning
the key to what an incarnation 'el world
would look like I always have this this
image in my mind of the story of King
David so the prophet Samuel is sent by
God to find the new king and God sends
him to a family to the family of Jesse
and so Samuel arrived and asked Jesse to
bring out his sons and so Jesse brings
out his sons and Samuel looks at each
son and he says no no no no no no none
of these are the King did you see Jesse
had a hidden son one which was not
obvious right away from the beginning he
is the smallest son the youngest son the
one which is out there in the field like
this pearl hidden in the field and so
Samuel chooses David and he anoints
David and then David is king but after
David is king you couldn't have told you
couldn't have you wouldn't been able to
say that David was King and his kingship
remained hidden it remained hidden until
the death of Saul and in that we can see
this notion see an anointing is the
revealing of centre-right it's a sign
from above the sign the finger of God
which comes down and says that one you
are my son today I have become your
father
and so it is if we think of of this
anointing we can we can use it at let's
say as a model we can look at how we can
engage in this world the church has
given us the sacrament and the
sacraments that's what they are they are
they are forms of anointing they are
showing us these centers they are the
finger of God that says this one this
one is my son that's what baptism and
chrismation is it shows the hidden
center that's what marriages you have
these two people why would you think
that those two people are one body there
is something hidden and the sacrament of
marriage is that showing is that
pointing to that hidden unity which
exists between the man and the woman
think of priesthood it is the same a
priesthood is an anointing this man this
priest this bishop and the same with
with confession confession is more as we
move away from the center as we move
away from this image of Christ in us
then it is this bringing back and the
same with holy unction this bringing
back towards this invisible center that
the spark the Christ hidden in our heart
hidden in our communion
say Gregory of Nyssa
he he he gives us in the life of Moses
this image of Moses who ascends the
mountain and as he and when he ascends
the mountain as he reaches the top of
the mountain
now think about everything I told you
think about a mountain goes up towards a
top towards a center towards a summit
and as he reaches the top of the
mountain God gives him the pattern of
the tabernacle right and and the
tabernacle is that very concentric space
right it is the Holy of Holies and the
holy and thee and the courts moving out
like that and he tells us that the
tabernacle that the pattern of the
tabernacle is Christ himself
he says I mean it he tells us that that
what he saw what Moses saw really is
Christ that's what he saw in the image
of the tabernacle and so we have we have
everything we need the the sacraments
they are not arbitrary the way the
church is laid out the art of the church
the architecture of the church our
liturgy none of that is arbitrary it is
the very shape of the world it is the
pointing to how the world works our
liturgy our sacraments and our and and
our communion that is the same pattern
as the Sun that rotates in the sky the
weeks the days it is the same pattern at
whatever it is that can unite us and
that can make us into families into
nations into anything that binds us that
is and even even
the scientific experiment it is the
pattern of reality so although we have
come to a disenchanted world there is
there is hope there is definitely hope
because that the enchanted world is
inevitable in a way it is maybe more
hidden now maybe people can't see it but
it is the heart of creation it is the
heart of reality it's the very shape of
the world and so as we ourselves engage
our life in Christ as we enter into our
heart to the measure that which we're
capable as we move away from those
passions that pull us apart that pull us
away from the heart where Christ shows
himself to us we are engaging and we are
part of reigniting this shining world
and obviously we don't we don't totally
have access to the fully shining world
at least I don't I know that I don't but
I have these glimpses right we have
these glimpses we have these these
moment where all of a sudden something
we see we see the grace of God pierced
through in these small moments and we
can trust now we can trust the story of
the saint when we read the story of the
Saints and you read the fathers who tell
us of their illumination and describe
this transfigured world where all things
are full of the presence of God where
the grace of God flows through
everything we can believe it even by
these little sparks that we encounter in
our lives in our daily lives so that is
my encouragement to all of you today so
thank you very much
[Applause]
yes so we have time for a few questions
I shall save mine for when we were in
the dining hall but the floor is open
for anyone who wishes to ask questions
so raise your hand I'm sorry if
sometimes I sound like a Baptist
preacher I actually did grow up in the
Baptist Church so sometimes try to I try
to hold it in but sometimes it comes out
for that so if you center yourself
around as you say we have filters kind
of a filter is a pre-thought filter and
we have feelings if you're centered on
Christ and feelings were something that
points to Christ if you have something
that you stir I think you still have a
feeling with the things because
so you have a few other things and
through this pre-thought feeling you
accept or reject things that come at you
or transform them into something that
you find them pleasing that pleases
centers so you're kind of enchanted one
what is enchanted with themselves and
their feelings I think that that sounds
absolutely right I think that sounds as
you know when you you know it's often
described as being if you're possessed
by a passion especially pride obviously
is the first the first passion that's
what it is in it when I talk about the
story of Christ as being the ultimate
version of that and that's where you can
see that for Christ who become thee for
Christ to be the Incarnation right there
he had to die and that he tells us to
take up our cross and I think that that
in order to you know and this notion of
entering into the heart and fitting into
your heart it happens through this
removal of the garments of skin as the
father's talk about as this sat this
sacrificing of our passions and anavar
and of our little idiosyncrasies that we
hold on to so much so I think I think I
think what you said is quite right
[Music]
[Music]
where our world so imminent eyes it's so
material the starquest
even conceive of a different way to
experience animals it just it's not
plausible right and he says that the
difference between the way that and
Christian can live within this though
versus someone who this entity is is
what open
[Music]
and at least the connection that maybe
your speaking was you're talking about
and you see you know you read in the
father's when they tell you things like
when you not to judge others that has to
do with that idea that you engage the
world with with a certain perception
where you're not out looking for the
other person's fault because you can
find them everybody has them right
everybody has a fault we can spend our
time pick nitpicking at everybody's
faults but to engage the world in a way
where you have this open generosity
towards others where you're looking for
Christ in that person right that's what
you're searching for when you engage
them and that you know that that's what
you said then you end up paying
attention to certain facts you end up
looking at that person through a certain
lens and that will transform the way you
you engage engage the world that's it
I'll have to look at that what do you
maybe can remind me later with the book
I'll look at that
[Music]
so there's a certain race well I think I
think that I think that what we would
need is a hierarchy I mean it's a
hierarchy where all things are ordered
and in their own place nothing in the
world is bad in itself there's nothing
that is in the world that is bad in
itself it's always bad because it is not
in its proper place and I think that
what has happened in terms of we could
not not science itself but it's a
scientism or the kind of scientism that
someone like Dawkins was having is that
he is trying to make the the materiality
reial
to all that there is and I think that
the proper way would be for just things
to be in a normal hierarchy is to
understand that that spiritual realities
come first moral realities come second
and then physical realities come third
let's say it could be could be set in
another way that's a way to see it and
so if when that happens then the
material world becomes subject to the
higher laws right it kind of happens in
on its own right now you know what the
let's say doing that would eliminate a
lot of the problems let's say all of the
problems of bioethics and the problems
of you know creating massive massive and
massive weapons of destruction that are
more and more destructive like if if if
things were ordered in the normal
hierarchy then we would pay attention to
certain facts we would want to use the
discoveries to serve those higher
purposes rather than whatever other
nefarious you know purposes we can find
for them I know that if that makes sense
and I'm sorry if it sounds like I'm I
have animosity towards fine
[Music]
we can accept the technical importance
for
[Music]
we don't follow there's a description in
the Bible I think it's the best way to
understand let's say this idea of where
science could fit in the whole thing is
that in the in them in the fall when
Adam and Eve fell you you actually see
that the fall is a series of Falls it's
not just the one fall so Adam and Eve
fall and then Cain kills Abel and then
there's like another fall and then and
then it goes all the way to the flood ok
so it's like this kind of fall up to
fall after fall and one of the Falls you
could say is that Cain goes out and he's
the one who found the first city and
then he develops technology you can read
it in the Bible
his descendants his descendents develop
different technology so you know it
talks about music making even and it
talks about metallurgy and the different
technologies are developed and so you
you get the sense that this kind of
technification is part of the fall
it's this moving away from the center ok
so you could say well that's really
negative that's very bad technology is
bad science is bad but no go to the very
end of the Bible go to the very very end
of the Bible the last vision we have is
a vision of this city and you have in
the center of the city the Tree of Life
and the river of life you have the
Garden of Eden basically in the center
of this city and so in that sense God
redeems this whole process this whole
fall this whole moving away from the
center all the way to the flood God in
the end redeems the whole thing and
creates this giant massive picture of
how everything is laid out you know and
in the end there is this technical world
that is there on the edge of this garden
and so there that it's if you know if
you think of it that in terms of that
kind of higher
then that is the I would say that is
would be the divine vision of what
science could be for us or what
technology can become so maybe that's my
last vision for you so I hope all of you
enjoyed the discussion I'd like to thank
dr. Gary Jenkins for organizing the
event Andrew Rodriguez who filmed
everything and also father Steve endemic
who recorded it and also like to thank
ancient faith you can find the audio
version on ancient fate I'll put the the
link to that below for those of you been
following the whole story of the
symbolic world you'll know that I
finally reached my kind of goal of two
thousand dollars that I'd put as a sign
that I need to take this to the next
level and so we have reached that goal
it's pretty exciting um
and that means that I have started
putting up a podcast and I'm also I have
also started doing patron only videos I
will do one probably once a month and
the one that I did was a Q&A that lasted
about an hour and a half I will take
questions from patreon from people who
are giving at the ten dollar level but
then the Q&A itself will be available
for anybody who's who's giving however
so if you give one dollar a month and
you have access to that Q&A or it might
also be another extra video on on a
subject like a folktale as I've talked
it depends on how many questions I have
and how interesting the questions are I
will also have the chat going during the
Q&A s and so if there are some good
questions coming up there I will
probably be answering those as well and
so yeah so I'll see you soon